Many adults may not know that simply being over 50 puts them at increased risk for shingles. Help prevent shingles in patients over 50 with shingricks. Shingricks is indicated for the prevention of herpes zoster, HZ, or shingles in adults 50 years of age or older. Consult the product monograph at gsk.ca slash shinricks slash PM for contra indications, warnings and precautions, adverse reactions, interactions, dosing and administration information. To request a product monograph or to report an adverse event, please call 1-800-387-7374.
许多成年人可能不知道，仅仅是年过50岁就会增加患带状疱疹的风险。使用Shingrix帮助50岁以上的患者预防带状疱疹。Shingrix适用于预防50岁及以上成年人的带状疱疹（HZ）。请查阅gsk.ca/shingrix/PM上的产品专论，了解禁忌症、警告和注意事项、不良反应、相互作用、剂量和给药信息。如需索取产品专论或报告不良事件，请致电1-800-387-7374。
Learn more at thinkshinricks.ca Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On Sunday December 12, 2010, 52-year-old Maricela Escobedo stood in Chihuahua City's main square, Plaza Hidalgo, surrounded by news camera crews and reporters. In view of the government palace, where the executive officers of the state governor were
欲了解更多信息，请访问thinkshingrix.ca。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。2010年12月12日星期日，52岁的玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多（Maricela Escobedo）站在奇瓦瓦市主广场伊达尔戈广场（Plaza Hidalgo），周围环绕着新闻摄影组和记者。在州长行政官员办公的政府大楼前，
housed, Maricela based a bombardment of questions. The mother of five, business owner and night nurse, responded to each one matter of factly. Yes, he's still in Mexico. Yes, I've had threats made against me. No, I won't be going into hiding. Despite everything, Maricela remained defiant. If this man is going to kill me, she announced, let him come and kill me here. By December 2008, it had been several months since anyone had heard from Ruby Freire. The 16-year-old lived in an apartment in the Mexican city of Juarez that was owned by her mother, Maricela Escobedo. Maricela had offered the residence to her daughter rent-free,
玛丽塞拉面对着连珠炮般的提问。这位五个孩子的母亲、企业主和夜班护士，实事求是地回答了每一个问题。是的，他还在墨西哥。是的，我收到过针对我的威胁。不，我不会躲起来。尽管发生了一切，玛丽塞拉依然不屈不挠。她宣布，如果这个人要杀我，就让他来这里杀我。到2008年12月，已经有几个月没有人收到鲁比·弗雷尔（Ruby Freire）的消息了。这位16岁的女孩住在墨西哥华雷斯市的一间公寓里，该公寓由她的母亲玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多拥有。玛丽塞拉免费将住所提供给女儿，
as while Ruby sought independence, she was struggling financially. Maricela initially thought Ruby hadn't been in touch because she couldn't afford to pay her phone bill and had lost access to the service. But as time wore on, Maricela's concerns grew. She sent her elder son, Juan, to visit Ruby and check up on her. He was surprised to find her apartment completely bare. 22-year-old Sergio Barraza was at his mother's house when there was a knock at the door. It was Maricela Escobedo. Sergio had been employed as a laborer at the workshop Maricela co-ran with her partner Jose Monge. He was also dating Maricela's daughter, Ruby. A few months earlier in late August, Sergio had taken a week off work. He'd told Maricela that
因为鲁比在寻求独立的同时，经济上正陷入困境。玛丽塞拉起初认为鲁比没有联系是因为她付不起电话费，导致服务中断。但随着时间推移，玛丽塞拉的担忧加剧了。她派大儿子胡安（Juan）去探望鲁比并查看她的情况。他惊讶地发现她的公寓空无一人。22岁的塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨（Sergio Barraza）当时正在他母亲家，这时有人敲门。来人是玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多。塞尔吉奥曾在玛丽塞拉与合伙人何塞·蒙格（Jose Monge）共同经营的车间里担任劳工。他当时也在和玛丽塞拉的女儿鲁比约会。几个月前，即8月下旬，塞尔吉奥请了一周假。他告诉玛丽塞拉，
he needed to care for his father who had been injured in a road accident. Weeks later, Sergio resigned. Now that Ruby was missing, Maricela figured her boyfriend might know a thing or two about her daughter's whereabouts. Yet, Sergio claimed that he hadn't seen Ruby since November, saying that she had run off with some tall white guy in a black car. Maricela gazed beyond where Sergio was standing and looked into his house. A lump rose in her throat. She could see Ruby and Sergio's 15-month-old daughter. Maricela knew Ruby would never willingly leave her child and was certain something bad must have happened. In the city of Juarez, anything was possible. Criminal groups known as cartels sought control of the city as it boarded the U.S.
他需要照顾在车祸中受伤的父亲。几周后，塞尔吉奥辞职了。现在鲁比失踪了，玛丽塞拉认为她的男朋友可能知道她女儿的下落。然而，塞尔吉奥声称自11月以来就没见过鲁比，说她和一个开着黑色汽车的高个白人男人私奔了。玛丽塞拉越过塞尔吉奥站的地方，看向他的房子。她的喉咙里涌起一股哽咽。她看到了鲁比和塞尔吉奥15个月大的女儿。玛丽塞拉知道鲁比绝不会自愿离开她的孩子，并确信一定发生了什么坏事。在华雷斯市，一切皆有可能。被称为卡特尔的犯罪集团寻求对该市的控制，因为它与美国接壤。
state of Texas. By 2008, the conflict had reached the boiling point. Gang violence engulfed the city as the incumbent Juarez cartel, known for decapitating and mutilating its rivals, fought off Sinaloa cartel, run by notorious drug lord El Chapo. Law-abiding citizens were caught in the crossfire and often fell victim to wider organized crimes such as racketeering and human trafficking. Fearing the worst for her daughter, Maricela Escobedo went to file a missing person report. The police refused to process it, believing Ruby had indeed run away with another man. Unconvinced and undeterred, Maricela began her own search. She bravely ventured into the city's most dangerous neighborhoods, scouring nightclubs and brothels,
德克萨斯州。到2008年，冲突已达到沸点。帮派暴力席卷了这座城市，以斩首和肢解对手而闻名的华雷斯卡特尔，击退了由臭名昭著的毒枭“矮子”（El Chapo）经营的锡那罗亚卡特尔。守法公民被卷入交火，并经常成为更广泛的有组织犯罪（如敲诈勒索和人口贩运）的受害者。担心女儿遭遇不测，玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多去提交了一份失踪人员报告。警方拒绝受理，认为鲁比确实是和另一个男人私奔了。玛丽塞拉没有被说服，也没有退缩，她开始了独自搜寻。她勇敢地闯入该市最危险的社区，搜寻夜总会和妓院，
while putting up posters and pressing passers-by for information. After almost a month of desperate and dogged searching, Maricela finally received a worthwhile tip-off. On Tuesday, January 27, 2009, a 17-year-old boy named Angel Veyes contacted Maricela, offering to tell her everything he knew. Angel was clearly terrified when speaking with Maricela. He trembled as he detailed what had happened one evening in late August 2008. Angel was hanging out with a group of friends when Sergio Barrasa and his brother Andy arrived. Sergio boasted that he had just killed his girlfriend, burnt her body, and then dumped her remains, quote, with the pigs.
同时张贴海报并向路人打听消息。经过近一个月的绝望和顽强搜寻，玛丽塞拉终于得到了一个有价值的线索。2009年1月27日星期二，一名叫安赫尔·维耶斯（Angel Veyes）的17岁男孩联系了玛丽塞拉，主动提出告诉她他所知道的一切。安赫尔在与玛丽塞拉交谈时显然非常害怕。他颤抖着详细描述了2008年8月下旬一个晚上发生的事情。安赫尔当时正和一群朋友在一起，这时塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨和他的兄弟安迪（Andy）到了。塞尔吉奥吹嘘说他刚刚杀死了他的女朋友，烧毁了她的尸体，然后把她的遗骸“扔给了猪”。
When Maricela initially questioned Sergio about Ruby's disappearance, he had told her that Ruby had run off with some tall white guy in a black car. It was a familiar lie. On a previous occasion, Maricela had entered her workshop looking for Ruby, and upon querying Sergio, he told her that Ruby had run away with a tall white man in a black car. Maricela accepted Sergio's word and made note of it in a missing person's report. Ruby then reappeared the following morning in tears. As detailed by Mexican news magazine, Proceso, it was at this point that Maricela discovered that Sergio had been grooming her daughter since Ruby was 14 years old. Sergio, who was then married
当玛丽塞拉最初询问塞尔吉奥关于鲁比失踪的事时，他告诉她鲁比和一个开着黑色汽车的高个白人男人私奔了。这是一个熟悉的谎言。在之前的一次场合中，玛丽塞拉曾进入她的车间寻找鲁比，在询问塞尔吉奥时，他告诉她鲁比和一个开着黑色汽车的高个白人男人私奔了。玛丽塞拉接受了塞尔吉奥的话，并在失踪人员报告中做了记录。鲁比随后在第二天早上流着泪出现了。正如墨西哥新闻杂志《Proceso》所详述的那样，正是在这一点上，玛丽塞拉发现塞尔吉奥从鲁比14岁起就开始诱骗她的女儿。塞尔吉奥当时已婚，
and had a five-year-old daughter, had convinced Ruby to run away with him. He kept her hidden in a warehouse a few blocks from his apartment. Upon realizing she had actually been abandoned by Sergio, Ruby returned home to her mother devastated. After this incident, Maricela fired Sergio and kept a close eye on Ruby. But Sergio didn't give up and tracked Ruby down at her school. In early May of 2006, he persuaded Ruby to move in with him. Maricela tried to convince her daughter to leave Sergio, who smashed the windshield of Maricela's car in retaliation. Given the age of consent in the state of Chihuahua was 18, Maricela considered reporting Sergio for statutory rape. However, she understood that Sergio's control
并且有一个五岁的女儿，他曾说服鲁比和他私奔。他把她藏在离他公寓几个街区的一个仓库里。在意识到自己确实被塞尔吉奥抛弃后，鲁比心碎地回到了母亲身边。这次事件后，玛丽塞拉解雇了塞尔吉奥，并密切关注鲁比。但塞尔吉奥没有放弃，他在学校找到了鲁比。2006年5月初，他说服鲁比和他住在一起。玛丽塞拉试图说服女儿离开塞尔吉奥，作为报复，塞尔吉奥砸碎了玛丽塞拉汽车的挡风玻璃。鉴于奇瓦瓦州的法定同意年龄是18岁，玛丽塞拉考虑举报塞尔吉奥犯有法定强奸罪。然而，她明白塞尔吉奥对鲁比的控制，
over Ruby ensured that her daughter would never testify against him. Then in October, Ruby discovered she was pregnant. Not wanting to damage her relationship with her daughter any further, Maricela changed tactics. She provided Sergio and Ruby with a rent-free apartment, rehired Sergio at the workshop, and offered to pay for all pre- and post-natal expenses. During her pregnancy, Ruby spent most of her time with her mother, and the two became close. But after Ruby gave birth, Sergio began the process of isolating her from her family. As the months passed, Maricela saw less and less of Ruby, and after waving goodbye to Ruby on Friday, August 22, 2008, Maricela never saw her again. Maricela was devastated after hearing
确保了她的女儿永远不会出庭指证他。后来在10月，鲁比发现自己怀孕了。为了不进一步损害她与女儿的关系，玛丽塞拉改变了策略。她为塞尔吉奥和鲁比提供了一间免租金的公寓，重新聘用了塞尔吉奥在车间工作，并主动提出支付所有产前和产后费用。怀孕期间，鲁比大部分时间都和母亲在一起，两人变得亲密起来。但鲁比生下孩子后，塞尔吉奥开始将她与家人隔离开来。随着几个月过去，玛丽塞拉见到鲁比的次数越来越少，在2008年8月22日星期五向鲁比挥手告别后，玛丽塞拉再也没有见过她。玛丽塞拉在听到
Angel Veys' story implicating Sergio in her daughter's murder. She went home and informed her other children what had happened to their sister, resolving to never rest until she brought Sergio Baraza to justice. Maricela convinced a wary unheld to repeat his story to the authorities, and with that, an investigation into Ruby Freire's disappearance finally began. It brought with it a startling revelation. On August 30, the previous year, Sergio Baraza's stepfather had personally attended the police station to report Ruby's murder. He said that Sergio had used his van to transport Ruby's body. Police officers visited Sergio's house, but upon finding no evidence of a murder having
安赫尔·维耶斯讲述塞尔吉奥参与她女儿谋杀案的故事后，感到悲痛欲绝。她回到家，告诉了其他孩子他们姐妹身上发生的事情，并下定决心，在将塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨绳之以法之前绝不休息。玛丽塞拉说服了警惕的安赫尔向当局重复他的故事，随之，对鲁比·弗雷尔失踪案的调查终于开始了。它带来了一个惊人的发现。前一年的8月30日，塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨的继父曾亲自前往警察局报告鲁比的谋杀案。他说塞尔吉奥曾用他的货车运送鲁比的尸体。警察访问了塞尔吉奥的家，但在没有发现那里发生谋杀案的证据后，
been committed there, they completely dismissed Sergio's stepfather's claims, and didn't pursue the matter any further. By the time all this came to light, Sergio was long gone. He'd fled the state of Chihuahua, taking Ruby's now 20-month-old daughter with him. At the time, any movement of a child across state lines required the consent of the mother. As Ruby was not officially listed as deceased, Sergio had effectively abducted their child. The abduction prompted a separate ministerial investigation, though it was Maricela's own detective work that tracked Sergio down to the city of Fresno, some 1,100 kilometers away. Sergio was promptly arrested, and Maricela was given custody of her granddaughter.
他们完全驳回了塞尔吉奥继父的说法，并没有进一步追究此事。当这一切曝光时，塞尔吉奥早已逃之夭夭。他逃离了奇瓦瓦州，带走了鲁比现在20个月大的女儿。当时，任何儿童跨州移动都需要母亲的同意。由于鲁比没有被正式列为死亡，塞尔吉奥实际上绑架了他们的孩子。这次绑架引发了一项单独的部长级调查，尽管是玛丽塞拉自己的侦探工作追踪到了约1100公里外的弗雷斯诺市。塞尔吉奥被迅速逮捕，玛丽塞拉获得了孙女的监护权。
While being transferred back to Juarez for the crime of abduction, Sergio made a spontaneous confession. He told the ministerial police officers that Ruby had been unfaithful to him, and in retaliation, he'd beaten her to death. With the help of his brother, Andy Baraza, Sergio transported Ruby's body in his stepfather's van to a landfill on the outskirts of Juarez. Bones and fat from animal carcasses were routinely dumped there, so the men believed it to be the ideal spot to burn Ruby's body. Sergio directed the ministerial police officers to the exact location of the pyre, where they uncovered 39 charred human bones that were confirmed to be the remains of Ruby Friaray.
在因绑架罪被押送回华雷斯的途中，塞尔吉奥做出了自发供述。他告诉部长级警官，鲁比对他不忠，作为报复，他将她殴打致死。在兄弟安迪·巴拉萨的帮助下，塞尔吉奥用他继父的货车将鲁比的尸体运到了华雷斯郊外的一个垃圾填埋场。动物尸体的骨头和脂肪经常被倾倒在那里，所以这些人认为这是焚烧鲁比尸体的理想地点。塞尔吉奥引导部长级警官找到了火葬堆的确切位置，他们在那里发现了39块烧焦的人骨，经证实是鲁比·弗雷尔的遗骸。
Sergio Baraza's trial for the murder of Ruby Friaray commenced in April 2010, the now-18-year-old Angel Veyes bravely testified against Sergio in court. He described the moment Sergio bragged about having killed Ruby before burning and dumping her remains. A ministerial police officer who arrested Sergio maintained that Sergio was solely responsible for what happened to Ruby, as she was found guilty of the murder. Sergio was solely responsible for what happened to Ruby, as she was found in the exact location and the exact manner Sergio had described. In an unexpected about face, Sergio's stepfather told the court that Sergio hadn't confessed to him that he'd killed Ruby, despite him
塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨谋杀鲁比·弗雷尔的审判于2010年4月开始，现年18岁的安赫尔·维耶斯勇敢地在法庭上指证塞尔吉奥。他描述了塞尔吉奥吹嘘自己杀死了鲁比，然后焚烧并倾倒她遗骸的时刻。逮捕塞尔吉奥的部长级警官坚称，塞尔吉奥对鲁比身上发生的事情负有全部责任，因为她被发现死于塞尔吉奥所描述的确切地点和确切方式。在一次意想不到的转变中，塞尔吉奥的继父告诉法庭，塞尔吉奥并没有向他承认杀死了鲁比，尽管他在事发后不久曾向警方这样说过。
saying so to police shortly after it happened. He was now claiming that Sergio had only confessed to assaulting Ruby. Some believed the man had changed his story to protect Sergio. In emotional testimony, Maricela Escobedo said that the defendant had destroyed her heart, her hope, and her faith, but not her life. She pledged that one day her family would smile again because life demands it. Maricela explicitly entrusted Sergio's faith into the hands of the court and concluded her testimony by addressing Sergio directly. May God forgive you, because I don't. Sergio Baraza chose not to testify. He did, however, take the opportunity to respond to Maricela, as was his right under Mexican law.
他现在声称塞尔吉奥只承认袭击了鲁比。一些人认为这个男人改变了说法是为了保护塞尔吉奥。在感人的证词中，玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多说，被告摧毁了她的心、她的希望和她的信仰，但没有摧毁她的生命。她发誓，总有一天她的家人会再次微笑，因为生活需要这样。玛丽塞拉明确地将塞尔吉奥的命运交到了法庭手中，并在结束证词时直接对塞尔吉奥说：“愿上帝宽恕你，因为我不会。”塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨选择不作证。然而，他确实利用这个机会回应了玛丽塞拉，这是他根据墨西哥法律享有的权利。
In front of the three presiding judges, Sergio acknowledged Maricela's lack of forgiveness and apologized to her for the great harm caused. He said that he'd found God while in jail on remand, but that otherwise, he had no words. After three days of court proceedings, the judges retired to deliberate. Maricela told reporters that she would accept nothing less than the maximum sentence for her daughter's murderer. The unanimous verdict was read aloud. For the murder of Ruby Freire, Sergio Baraza was found not guilty. After both literally and figuratively picking herself up off the floor, Maricela Escobedo appealed to the state's higher court, claiming that the trial's original three judges had made
在三位主审法官面前，塞尔吉奥承认了玛丽塞拉的不宽恕，并为造成的巨大伤害向她道歉。他说他在还押候审期间找到了上帝，但除此之外，他无话可说。经过三天的法庭诉讼，法官们退庭审议。玛丽塞拉告诉记者，她绝不接受对她女儿凶手的任何低于最高刑罚的判决。一致的判决被大声宣读。对于鲁比·弗雷尔的谋杀案，塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨被判无罪。在身体和精神上从打击中恢复过来后，玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多向州高等法院提起上诉，声称审判的最初三位法官在做出决定时犯了
serious errors of law in reaching their decision. The appeal also highlighted the deficiencies in the investigation itself, particularly the little effort made by authorities to examine anything beyond the evidence and witnesses that Maricela herself uncovered. They hadn't even bothered to track down unhell of Veys' friends, who had also witnessed Sergio bragging about Ruby's murder. It was also found that the murder trial judges had incorrectly disregarded unhell's testimony, as he say, when it should have been considered circumstantial evidence. Despite Ruby's remains having been found dumped and burnt, the original judges had focused on the lack of a formal cause of death to conclude that no homicide had been committed. In contrast,
严重的法律错误。上诉还强调了调查本身的缺陷，特别是当局在审查玛丽塞拉本人发现的证据和证人之外的内容方面所做的努力很少。他们甚至没有费心去追踪安赫尔·维耶斯的朋友，他们也目睹了塞尔吉奥吹嘘谋杀鲁比的事。还发现谋杀案审判法官错误地将安赫尔的证词视为传闻，而本应将其视为间接证据。尽管鲁比的遗骸被发现是被倾倒和焚烧的，但最初的法官却专注于缺乏正式的死因，从而得出没有发生谋杀案的结论。相比之下，
the appeal court said it was a certainty that Ruby had been murdered. While the state appellate court supported the judge's original decision to disregard Sergio's confession to police, as it was given without a lawyer present, they determined that Sergio's in court apology to Maricela Escobedo should have been considered a confession, as it was in the presence of his lawyer. In late May 2010, the appeal court overturned the acquittal. Sergio Baraza was found guilty of the murder of Ruby Freire and sentenced to 50 years in prison. The sentence was meaningless. Before the appeal court handed down its decision, Sergio, still a free man at this point, once again fled the state of Chihuahua. His whereabouts were unknown.
上诉法院表示，鲁比被谋杀是肯定的。虽然州上诉法院支持法官最初不采纳塞尔吉奥向警方供述的决定，因为那是在没有律师在场的情况下做出的，但他们确定塞尔吉奥在法庭上向玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多的道歉应被视为供述，因为它是在他的律师在场的情况下做出的。2010年5月下旬，上诉法院推翻了无罪判决。塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨被判谋杀鲁比·弗雷尔罪名成立，并被判处50年监禁。这个判决毫无意义。在上诉法院做出决定之前，当时仍是自由人的塞尔吉奥再次逃离了奇瓦瓦州。他的下落不明。
Fueled by frustration and anger, Maricela Escobedo quit her nursing job and left her workshop business to join forces with a human rights defence group called Justice for Daughters. Alongside her family and other group members, Maricela began a crusade for justice. She marched on the country's capital of Mexico City, armed with life-sized photographs of Ruby, banners demanding justice, and wanted posters featuring Sergio Baraza. Covering nearly 1,800 kilometres, Maricela met with city and town officials along the way to explain her case and request that they turn over Sergio should he be found within their limits. She drew media attention in any way she could, even walking naked with the
在沮丧和愤怒的驱使下，玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多辞去了护理工作，离开了她的车间生意，加入了名为“女儿正义”（Justice for Daughters）的人权保护组织。与她的家人和其他组织成员一起，玛丽塞拉开始了正义的十字军东征。她向该国首都墨西哥城进军，带着鲁比真人大小的照片、要求正义的横幅以及印有塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨头像的通缉海报。行程近1800公里，玛丽塞拉沿途会见了城市和城镇官员，解释她的案件并要求如果塞尔吉奥在他们的管辖范围内被发现，就将他移交。她尽可能地吸引媒体关注，甚至赤身裸体，只用
just a banner wrapped around her body. Maricela told reporters that she was marching against the systemic impunity for those who commit violence against women. Soon, the case of Ruby Freire became the latest symbol of the growing femicide epidemic in Mexico. After nearly four weeks of daily marching, Maricela finally arrived in Mexico City, where she requested an audience with President Felipe Calderón. He refused to see her. Upon her return to Juarez, Maricela was dismayed to discover that, although Sergio was a convicted murderer and a wanted fugitive, the authorities had done absolutely nothing to locate him.
一条横幅裹在身上。玛丽塞拉告诉记者，她是在抗议对那些对女性实施暴力的人的系统性有罪不罚。很快，鲁比·弗雷尔案成为了墨西哥日益严重的杀害女性流行病的最新象征。经过近四周的每日游行，玛丽塞拉终于抵达墨西哥城，在那里她请求会见费利佩·卡尔德龙（Felipe Calderón）总统。他拒绝见她。回到华雷斯后，玛丽塞拉沮丧地发现，尽管塞尔吉奥是一名被定罪的杀人犯和通缉逃犯，但当局根本没有采取任何行动来定位他。
Once again, she was forced to take matters into her own hands. Acting on a hunch, she returned to Fresno, the city where she had previously found Sergio when he was on the run in June 2009. It didn't take long for Maricela to learn where he was living now. She informed authorities and on Tuesday, July 13, 2010, they descended on the property. Despite the dozens of heavily armed state, federal and military police, Sergio was able to escape out the rear of the house before disappearing into the night. Months passed and the authorities made zero effort to pick up Sergio's trail. It was left to Maricela to hunt down her daughter's killer.
再一次，她被迫亲自处理这件事。凭着直觉，她回到了弗雷斯诺，那是她之前在2009年6月塞尔吉奥潜逃时找到他的城市。玛丽塞拉没过多久就打听到了他现在住的地方。她通知了当局，2010年7月13日星期二，他们突袭了该房产。尽管有数十名全副武装的州、联邦和军事警察，塞尔吉奥还是在消失在夜色中之前从房子后门逃脱了。几个月过去了，当局在追踪塞尔吉奥方面毫无作为。寻找她女儿凶手的任务留给了玛丽塞拉。
By now, rumours were circulating that Sergio was under the protection of the state's cartel, Los Zetas. In time, Maricela began receiving veiled threats, including from Sergio's brother, Andy Baraza. Pressing forward irrespective of the danger, Maricela eventually discovered Sergio's whereabouts. As she suspected, he hadn't left Fresno. When Maricela approached the house, a young woman opened the door. The girl said she was Sergio's girlfriend and that he was indeed a member of Los Zetas. Maricela now understood why the Fresno authorities were unwilling to arrest Sergio. In 2010, Los Zetas was the largest cartel in Mexico, described by the United States Drug Enforcement Administration as the most technologically advanced, sophisticated and
到目前为止，有传言称塞尔吉奥受到该州卡特尔“洛斯塞塔斯”（Los Zetas）的保护。随着时间的推移，玛丽塞拉开始收到隐晦的威胁，包括来自塞尔吉奥的兄弟安迪·巴拉萨的威胁。不顾危险继续前进，玛丽塞拉最终发现了塞尔吉奥的下落。正如她所怀疑的那样，他没有离开弗雷斯诺。当玛丽塞拉走近房子时，一个年轻女子打开了门。女孩说她是塞尔吉奥的女朋友，他确实是“洛斯塞塔斯”的成员。玛丽塞拉现在明白了为什么弗雷斯诺当局不愿意逮捕塞尔吉奥。2010年，“洛斯塞塔斯”是墨西哥最大的卡特尔，被美国缉毒局描述为技术最先进、最复杂和
violent cartel. Los Zetas controlled the majority of the country's states. As far as the Fresno authorities were concerned, Sergio Baraza, who had risen rapidly through the ranks of Los Zetas, was untouchable. Despite this revelation, Maricela refused to back down. She had spent two years fighting for justice and had taken an immense toll on her health and well-being. But this didn't dissuade her from commencing a sit-in vigil in Chihuahua City's main square, Plaza Hidalgo, directly in front of the government palace. Starting on December 5, 2010, Maricela vowed to remain in the plaza until Sergio Baraza was arrested. She aimed to garner the attention of the new state governor,
最暴力的卡特尔。“洛斯塞塔斯”控制了该国的大部分州。就弗雷斯诺当局而言，在“洛斯塞塔斯”中迅速晋升的塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨是不可触碰的。尽管有这一发现，玛丽塞拉拒绝退缩。她花了两年时间为正义而战，这对她的健康和福祉造成了巨大的损害。但这并没有阻止她在奇瓦瓦市主广场伊达尔戈广场，直接在政府大楼前开始静坐守夜。从2010年12月5日开始，玛丽塞拉发誓要留在广场上，直到塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨被捕。她的目标是引起新任州长，
Cesar Duarte, who'd been elected on the promise that he'd bring order to Chihuahua. For days, Maricela sat in the plaza surrounded by posters and banners denouncing the lack of justice for her daughter. She was supported by a procession of family, friends, and fellow human rights defenders. Then, on December 8, Maricela confronted Governor Duarte in front of the government palace, calling him out on his failures and embarrassing him in front of the media. In response, a visibly annoyed Duarte invited Maricela to speak directly with the state attorney general, Carlos Salas. Maricela accepted the offer, and in the meeting, she told Salas all she had uncovered regarding Sergio Baraza's whereabouts, links to Los Zetas, and the ineffective policing
塞萨尔·杜阿尔特（Cesar Duarte）的注意，他当选时承诺会为奇瓦瓦带来秩序。几天来，玛丽塞拉坐在广场上，周围环绕着谴责为她女儿伸张正义不力的海报和横幅。她得到了家人、朋友和人权捍卫者同伴的支持。然后，在12月8日，玛丽塞拉在政府大楼前与杜阿尔特州长对峙，指责他的失败，并在媒体面前让他难堪。作为回应，明显恼火的杜阿尔特邀请玛丽塞拉直接与州总检察长卡洛斯·萨拉斯（Carlos Salas）交谈。玛丽塞拉接受了邀请，在会议中，她告诉萨拉斯她所发现的关于塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨下落、与“洛斯塞塔斯”的联系以及无效的警务工作的一切，
that allowed him to roam free. Salas assured Maricela that action would be taken. Maricela then resumed her peaceful protest in front of the government palace as a constant reminder to Duarte and Salas to make good on their promise. One week into her sit-in, Maricela told reporters that she had received many threats from Sergio's family and the cartel, including that Los Zetas do not forgive nor forget, and failure to abide by their rules would cost her her life. Maricela refused to go into hiding. Instead, she continued to call out the government's continued inaction.
这让他得以逍遥法外。萨拉斯向玛丽塞拉保证会采取行动。玛丽塞拉随后在政府大楼前恢复了她的和平抗议，作为对杜阿尔特和萨拉斯兑现承诺的持续提醒。静坐一周后，玛丽塞拉告诉记者，她收到了来自塞尔吉奥家人和卡特尔的许多威胁，包括“洛斯塞塔斯”不宽恕也不遗忘，不遵守他们的规则将让她付出生命的代价。玛丽塞拉拒绝躲藏。相反，她继续呼吁政府持续的不作为。
What are they waiting for? she asked. For him to finish me? Maricela then threw down the only gauntlet she had left. She announced that if Sergio Baraza wanted her dead, then he would have to do it right in front of the governor's palace, to the shame of the bureaucrats that worked behind its doors. Four days later, on the evening of Thursday, December 16, 2010, Maricela and her brother Ricardo were quietly sitting in protest at a table set up at the front edge of the plaza. Just after 8pm, a white sedan pulled up near where Maricela and Ricardo sat. A man dressed in light trousers and a dark top slipped out of the passenger side of the car.
“他们在等什么？”她问道。“等他解决我吗？”玛丽塞拉随后抛出了她仅剩的挑战。她宣布，如果塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨想要她死，那么他必须在政府大楼前动手，让在其门后工作的官僚们蒙羞。四天后，2010年12月16日星期四晚上，玛丽塞拉和她的兄弟里卡多（Ricardo）安静地坐在广场前沿的一张桌子旁抗议。晚上8点刚过，一辆白色轿车停在玛丽塞拉和里卡多坐的地方附近。一名穿着浅色裤子和深色上衣的男子从车内副驾驶一侧溜了出来。
After taking a few steps, he stood directly behind Maricela. The man pulled out a 9mm pistol, pressed it against Maricela's head, and fired. The gun jammed. Maricela leapt from her seat and took off. Ricardo grabbed his own chair and threw it at the gunman, just as Maricela sprinted across two lanes of moving traffic towards the perceived safety of the government palace. The gunman caught up to her just before she reached the other side of the road. In mid-stride, he raised his gun to the back of Maricela's head again and pulled the trigger. There was no obstruction this time. Maricela collapsed to the ground directly in front
走了几步后，他直接站在玛丽塞拉身后。该男子掏出一把9毫米手枪，抵住玛丽塞拉的头部，扣动了扳机。枪卡壳了。玛丽塞拉从座位上跳起来跑开了。里卡多抓起自己的椅子扔向枪手，就在玛丽塞拉冲过两条车流向政府大楼的所谓安全地带时。枪手在她到达马路另一边之前追上了她。在奔跑中，他再次将枪举到玛丽塞拉的后脑勺并扣动了扳机。这次没有障碍。玛丽塞拉倒在政府大楼入口前，
of the government palace's entrance. The gunman scrambled back into the white sedan and it sped off into the night. Traffic slowed only for a moment before moving on. A pedestrian within meters of Maricela's prone bleeding body turned briefly to observe what had taken place, then continued onwards on their journey. The only person who seemed to care about what had happened was Ricardo, who banged desperately on the locked doors of the government palace, screaming for help. In the wake of the public outcry and condemnation that followed Maricela Escobedo's murder, authorities were quick to blame Sergio Baraza for orchestrating the assassination.
枪手匆忙回到白色轿车中，车子消失在夜色中。交通只减速了一瞬间就继续前行。距离玛丽塞拉倒下的流血身体几米远的一名行人短暂地转过身观察发生了什么，然后继续他们的旅程。唯一似乎关心发生什么事的人是里卡多，他绝望地敲打着政府大楼锁着的门，尖叫着求救。在玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多被谋杀后引发的公众抗议和谴责中，当局很快将暗杀归咎于塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨。
Chihuahua governor, Cesar Duarte, told reporters that he was filled with frustration and indignation and called for the judges who had initially acquitted Sergio to be sacked. President Felipe Calderón likewise tweeted, It is unfortunate that the Chihuahua judges released the confessed murderer of Ruby. That impunity led to the murder of Maricela Escobedo. Hours after Maricela's funeral, the workshop that she ran with her partner, Jose Monje, was destroyed by fire. Jose's brother Manuel, who had been looking after the shop, was missing. Manuel was found dead the following day. His hands and feet were bound with duct tape and a plastic
奇瓦瓦州州长塞萨尔·杜阿尔特告诉记者，他充满了沮丧和愤慨，并呼吁将最初判处塞尔吉奥无罪的法官解职。费利佩·卡尔德龙总统同样发推文称：“奇瓦瓦法官释放了鲁比的供认杀人犯，这是不幸的。这种有罪不罚导致了玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多的谋杀。”玛丽塞拉葬礼几小时后，她与合伙人何塞·蒙格共同经营的车间被大火烧毁。一直照看商店的何塞的兄弟曼努埃尔（Manuel）失踪了。曼努埃尔第二天被发现死亡。他的手脚被胶带捆绑，一个塑料袋
bag was pulled tight over his head. The official response was that Manuel's murder was not linked to Maricela's. Yet Maricela's oldest son, Juan, knew what was. In the Netflix documentary, The Three Deaths of Maricela Escobedo, Juan recalled how people had also come looking for him that day. He realized then that as long as he and his family remained in Mexico, their lives were in danger. Leaving everything they'd worked for behind, three generations of Escobedos fled across the border into the United States that very night. Back in Juárez, less than three months after Maricela and Manuel's murders, six men burst into a home and shot dead at the three adults inside.
紧紧套在他的头上。官方回应是曼努埃尔的谋杀与玛丽塞拉的无关。然而，玛丽塞拉的大儿子胡安知道事实并非如此。在Netflix纪录片《玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多的三次死亡》中，胡安回忆起那天人们也来找他。他当时意识到，只要他和家人留在墨西哥，他们的生命就处于危险之中。抛下他们为之奋斗的一切，三代埃斯科贝多人当晚逃过了边境进入美国。回到华雷斯，在玛丽塞拉和曼努埃尔被谋杀不到三个月后，六名男子闯入一所房子，枪杀了里面的三名成年人。
The offenders, all barely out of their teens, fled immediately after the shooting. Their victims were the now 20-year-old Angel Veyes, his father, and his aunt. A year and a half later, in October 2012, Chihuahua authorities announced that they had arrested Maricela Escobedo's killer. The man they named was 30-year-old lifelong gang member Jose Jimenez, known as El Wicked. El Wicked was already in custody for the massacre of Maricela Escobedo's 16 people in a bar in Chihuahua six months earlier. A gun used in this crime was matched to the one used to execute Maricela. According to the authorities, El Wicked had confessed to carrying out the hit on Maricela under joint instructions from the Juárez cartel and a loss of Zetas.
罪犯们都刚过十几岁，在枪击后立即逃离。他们的受害者是现在20岁的安赫尔·维耶斯、他的父亲和他的姑姑。一年半后，即2012年10月，奇瓦瓦当局宣布他们逮捕了玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多的凶手。他们点名的人是30岁的终身帮派成员何塞·希门尼斯（Jose Jimenez），被称为“邪恶者”（El Wicked）。“邪恶者”因六个月前在奇瓦瓦一家酒吧屠杀玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多的16人而已被拘留。在此案中使用的枪支与执行玛丽塞拉死刑的枪支相匹配。据当局称，“邪恶者”承认在华雷斯卡特尔和“洛斯塞塔斯”的共同指示下执行了对玛丽塞拉的暗杀。
Maricela had become too much of a nuisance for them. This revelation was just another slap in the face of Maricela's loved ones, served by a government they regarded as corrupt and apathetic. In an exclusive interview with Mexican news magazine Proceso, Juan expressed his opinion that El Wicked was merely a high-ranking cartel scapegoat whose arrest enabled the government to close his mother's case. Juan explained that his uncle Ricardo remembered the man who murdered Maricela and that man was not El Wicked. When shown a photo lineup of known gang members, Ricardo recognized one man as Maricela's killer with 100% certainty. The photo was of Sergio Barraza's brother, Andy.
玛丽塞拉对他们来说已经成了太大的麻烦。这一发现只是对玛丽塞拉亲人的又一次打脸，由一个他们认为腐败和冷漠的政府所为。在接受墨西哥新闻杂志《Proceso》的独家采访时，胡安表达了他的观点，即“邪恶者”只是一个高级卡特尔替罪羊，他的被捕使政府能够结案他母亲的案件。胡安解释说，他的叔叔里卡多记得谋杀玛丽塞拉的人，那个人不是“邪恶者”。当看到已知帮派成员的照片阵容时，里卡多以100%的确定性认出了一名男子是玛丽塞拉的凶手。照片上的人是塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨的兄弟安迪。
He had previously been accused of helping Sergio dispose of Ruby Friar's body. Ricardo had never seen Andy Barraza prior to the night of Maricela's murder, but he never forgot his face. Juan and Ricardo had passed this information to the authorities, but were ignored. After naming Andy Barraza as Maricela's killer, Juan then went one step further and openly accused the Chihuahua government of complicity in his mother's death. He explained that Maricela effectively signed her own death warrant when she revealed all of her information to the Attorney General, Carlos Salas. It was also discovered that in addition to the usual 24-hour security personnel that routinely patrolled the government palace, a personal security detail had been promised to
他之前曾被指控帮助塞尔吉奥处理鲁比·弗雷尔的尸体。里卡多在玛丽塞拉被谋杀的那晚之前从未见过安迪·巴拉萨，但他从未忘记他的脸。胡安和里卡多已将此信息传达给当局，但被忽视了。在点名安迪·巴拉萨为玛丽塞拉的凶手后，胡安更进一步，公开指责奇瓦瓦政府在他母亲的死亡中存在共谋。他解释说，玛丽塞拉在向总检察长卡洛斯·萨拉斯透露她所有的信息时，实际上签署了自己的死刑判决书。还发现，除了通常在政府大楼巡逻的24小时安保人员外，还承诺为
Maricela. However, when the doors of the government palace closed at 8pm on December 16, 2010, Maricela was shot minutes later with no security staff inside. According to Juan, the area had been intentionally cleared, and Andy Barraza knew he would not be interrupted. On Friday, November 16, 2012, four members of Los Zetas were killed in an armed clash with the Mexican army. Among those killed was Sergio Barraza. Eight days later, Governor Cesar Duarte announced that with Sergio dead and El Wicked in custody, the cases of Ruby Friarra and Maricela Escobedo were officially closed. However, as his trial approached, El Wicked retracted his confession to Maricela's murder.
玛丽塞拉提供个人安保小组。然而，当2010年12月16日晚上8点政府大楼的门关闭时，玛丽塞拉在几分钟后被枪杀，里面没有安保人员。据胡安说，该区域已被故意清空，安迪·巴拉萨知道他不会受到干扰。2012年11月16日星期五，四名“洛斯塞塔斯”成员在与墨西哥军队的武装冲突中丧生。死者中包括塞尔吉奥·巴拉萨。八天后，塞萨尔·杜阿尔特州长宣布，随着塞尔吉奥的死亡和“邪恶者”的被捕，鲁比·弗雷尔和玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多的案件正式结案。然而，随着审判临近，“邪恶者”撤回了他对谋杀玛丽塞拉的供述。
He said it had been made under torture and threats against his wife and children. These claims, along with Ricardo's identification that Andy Barraza carried out the slaying, meant that the prosecution could have a difficult time convicting El Wicked for Maricela's murder. On Wednesday, December 31, 2014, before his trial commenced, El Wicked was found dead in prison. The authorities initially said he had died from a heart attack, but were later forced to admit that El Wicked had been strangled to death by another inmate, who had somehow gained access to his cell. By January 2015, all the members of the Escobedo family who had escaped into America had been granted permanent political asylum. The immigration judge who ruled in favor of Juan's
他说这是在酷刑和对他妻子及孩子的威胁下做出的。这些说法，加上里卡多对安迪·巴拉萨实施杀戮的指认，意味着检方可能很难因谋杀玛丽塞拉而给“邪恶者”定罪。2014年12月31日星期三，在审判开始前，“邪恶者”被发现死在监狱里。当局最初说他死于心脏病发作，但后来被迫承认“邪恶者”是被另一名囚犯勒死的，该囚犯不知何故进入了他的牢房。到2015年1月，所有逃往美国的埃斯科贝多家族成员都获得了永久政治庇护。裁定支持胡安申请的移民法官
application specifically stated that, the Mexican government is unable or unwilling to control actors who persecute human rights defenders. In October 2020, the Inter-American Commission on Human Rights announced that it would give Mexico three months to provide its response to the Escobedo's complaints of human rights violations in relation to the murders of Ruby and Maricela, before the Commission considered the case. The Escobedo's hoped that one day soon, Mexico would be held publicly and internationally responsible for these human rights violations. By December 2020, shortly after the Commission's announcement and the release of the Netflix documentary The Three Deaths of Maricela Escobedo, both the governor of Chihuahua
明确指出：“墨西哥政府无法或不愿控制迫害人权捍卫者的行为者。”2020年10月，美洲人权委员会宣布，在委员会审议此案之前，将给墨西哥三个月的时间，就埃斯科贝多关于鲁比和玛丽塞拉谋杀案相关人权侵犯的投诉做出回应。埃斯科贝多人希望有一天，墨西哥能因这些侵犯人权的行为在公共和国际上承担责任。到2020年12月，在委员会宣布和Netflix纪录片《玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多的三次死亡》发布后不久，奇瓦瓦州州长
and the Mexican president announced the reopening of Maricela Escobedo's murder investigation. That same year, Andy Baraza, in prison in Texas for unrelated crimes, gave an exclusive interview to the makers of the Netflix documentary. Andy openly admitted that Sergio, who had gained senior ranking within Los Zetas, had organized the hit on Maricela and the arson attack on her workshop. Andy denied killing Maricela. As of 2022, the investigation into Maricela's murder is still ongoing. It has been more than a decade, and each year since, all across Mexico,
和墨西哥总统都宣布重新调查玛丽塞拉·埃斯科贝多的谋杀案。同年，在德克萨斯州监狱因无关罪行服刑的安迪·巴拉萨接受了Netflix纪录片制作人的独家采访。安迪公开承认，在“洛斯塞塔斯”中获得高级职位的塞尔吉奥组织了对玛丽塞拉的暗杀和对她车间的纵火袭击。安迪否认杀害了玛丽塞拉。截至2022年，对玛丽塞拉谋杀案的调查仍在进行中。已经过去了十多年，此后的每一年，在整个墨西哥，
citizens continue to march against what they perceive as government-sanctioned impunity granted to perpetrators of violence against women. Maricela is one of their symbols. When speaking at his mother's funeral, Juan Escobedo said, she fought to her last breath and died on the front lines. My mom was a hero because she did things that no one in the city had ever done. She fought on her own against rain and thunder. Even when she seemed like she would break down, she got up again and taught us a lesson in fortitude. I ask all of you to give my mom a big round of applause.
公民们继续游行，反对他们认为政府默许对女性暴力实施者给予有罪不罚。玛丽塞拉是他们的象征之一。在母亲的葬礼上发言时，胡安·埃斯科贝多说：“她战斗到最后一口气，死在了前线。我妈妈是英雄，因为她做了城里没有人做过的事。她独自在风雨中战斗。即使在她看起来要崩溃的时候，她又站了起来，给我们上了一堂坚韧的课。我请大家为我妈妈热烈鼓掌。”
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
目前还没有关于本剧集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。